hi everyone thanks for coming to our
cs35 lecture today uh so today we're
honor to have Jim B from Nvidia we'll be
talking about generous agents in open
ended worlds and he's a senior AI
research scientist at Nvidia where his
mission is to build generally capable AI
agents with applications to gaming
Robotics and software Automation and it
research spans from condition models
multimod AI reinforcement learning and
open-ended um learning he obtained his
PhD degree in computer science from here
Stanford advised by Professor
p and previously he did research
internships at openi Google AI as well
as um mil Quebec AI
Institute uh so yeah we're um um give it
up for
Jim yeah thanks for having me so I want
to start with a story of two
kittens um it's a story that gave me a
lot of inspiration over the career over
my career so I want to share this one
first you know back in
1963 there were two scientists from MIT
helden Hine they did this ingenious
experiment where they put two newborn
kittens in this device and the kittens
have not seen the visual world yet so
it's kind of like a Maro round
where the two kittens are linked by a
rigid mechanical bar so their movements
are like exactly mered and there's an
active kitten on the right hand side and
that's the only one able to move freely
and then transmit the motion over over
this link to the passive kitten uh which
is confined to the basket and cannot
really control its own
movements and then after a couple of
days helden high kind of take the
kittens out of this marry Go Round And
then did visual testing on them and they
found that only the active kitten was
able to develop a healthy visual motor
Loop like you know responding correctly
to approaching objects or like visual
Cliffs but a passive kitten did not have
a healthy visual
system so I find this experiment
fascinating because it shows the
importance of having this embodied
active experience to really ground um a
system of
intelligence and let's put this
experiment in today's AI context right
we actually have a very powerful passive
kitten and that is
chbt it passively observes and rehearses
uh the text on the internet and it
doesn't have any embodiment and because
of this its knowledge is kind of
abstract and ungrounded and that
partially contributes to the fact that
CH hallucinates things that are just
incompatible with our common sense and
our physical
experience and I believe the future
belongs to active kidneys which
translates to generalist agents they are
the decision makers in a constant
feedback loop and they're embodied in
this fully immersive world uh they're
also not mutually exclusive with the
passive kidney and in fact I see the
active embodiment part as a layer on top
of the passive Pro training from lots
and lots of internet
data so are we there yet have we
achieved
journalized you know back in 2016 I
remember was like spring of 2016 I was
sending an undergraduate class at
Columbia University but I wasn't paying
attention to the lecture I was watching
a board game tournament on my laptop and
this screenshot was the moment when
arago versus Lisa do and ARA go won
three matches out of five and became the
first ever to beat a human champion at
the game of Go you know I remember the
ad journaling that day right I've seeing
history unfold oh my God we are you know
finally getting to hii and everyone is
like so excited and I think that was the
moment when AI agents enter the
mainstream but you know like when the
Simon Fates I felt that even though ARA
go was so mighty and so great It could
only do one thing and one thing
alone right and afterwards you know in
2019 there were more impressive
achievements like open a five beating
the human Champions at the game of DOTA
and ARA star from Deep Mind be Starcraft
but all of these with arago they all
have a single kind of theme and that is
to be the opponent there is this one
objective that the agent needs to do and
the models trained on Dota or Go Cannot
generalize to any other tasks it cannot
even play other games like Super Mario
or Minecraft and the world is fixed and
have very little room for like
open-ended creativity and
exploration so I argue that a journalist
agent should have the following
essential properties first it should be
able to pursue very complex semantically
rich and open world objectives basically
you explain what you want in natural
language and the agent should perform
the actions for you in a dynamic world
and second the agent should have a large
amount of pre-trained knowledge instead
of knowing only a few Concepts that's
extremely specific to the task and third
massively multitask right A Generous
agent as the name implies needs to do
more than just a couple of things it
should be um in the best case infinitely
multitask as expressive as human
language can
dictate so what does it take
correspondingly we need three main
ingredients first is the environment
right the environment needs to be
open-ended enough because the agent's
capability is upper bounded by the
environment
complexity and I'd argue that Earth is
actually a perfect example because it's
so open-ended this world we live in that
it allows an algorithm called Natural
Evolution to produce all the diverse
forms and behaviors of Life on this
planet so can we have a simulator that
is essentially a Loi Earth but we can
still run it on the lab
clusters and second we need to provide
agent with massive pre-training data
because exploration in an open-ended
world from scratch is just intractable
and the data will serve at least two
purposes one as a reference manual on
how to do things and second as a
guidance on what are the interesting
things worth
pursuing and you know GPT is only at
least up to gbd4 it only learns from
Pure text on the web but can we provide
agent with much richer data such as
video walk through or like multimedia uh
Wiki documents uh and other media forms
and finally once we have the environment
and the database we are ready to train
Foundation models for the agents and it
should be flexible enough to pursue the
open-ended tasks without any task
specific assumptions and also scalable
enough to compress all of the multi
modal data that I just described and
here language I argue will play at least
two key roles one is as a simple
intutive interface to communicate a task
to communicate the human intentions to
the agent and second as a bridge to
ground all of the multimodal concepts
and
signals and that train of thought landed
Us in Minecraft the bestselling video
game of all
time and for those who are unfamiliar
Minecraft is a procedure generated 3D
voxo World and in the game you can
basically do whatever your heart
desires and what's so special about the
game is that unlike ARA go St Starcraft
or DOTA Minecraft defines no particular
objective to maximize no particular
opponent opponent to beat and doesn't
even have a fixed storyline and that
makes it very well suited as a truly
open-ended AI playground and here we see
people doing extremely impressive things
in Minecraft like this is a YouTube
video where a gamer built the entire
Hogwarts CLE block by block by hand in a
game and here's another example of some
one just digging a big hole in the
ground and then making this beautiful
underground temple with a river nearby
it's all crafted by
hand and one more this is someone
building a functioning CPU circuit
inside the game because there are
something called red stone in Minecraft
that you can build circuits out of it
like logical Gates and actually the game
is touring complete you can you know
simulate a computer inside the game just
think about how crazy that that is and
here I want to highlight a number that
is 140 million active players and just
to put this number in P perspective this
is more than twice the population of
UK and that is the amount of people
playing Minecraft on a daily
basis and you know it just so happens
that gamers are generally happier than
phds so they love to stream and share
what they're doing and that produces a
huge amount of data every every day
online and there's this Treasure Trove
of learning
materials um that we can tap into for
training journalist agents you know
remember the data is the key for
foundation
models so we introduce mind Dojo a new
open framework to help the community
develop generally capable agents using
Minecraft as a kind of primordial
soup mind Dojo features three major
parts an open ended environment and
internet skill knowledge base and then a
generous agent developed with a
simulator and massive data so let's zoom
in the first
one here's a sample gallery of the
interesting things that you can do with
mind dojo's
API we feature a massive benchmarking
Suite of more than 3,000 tasks and this
is by far the largest open- source Asian
Benchmark to our knowledge and we
Implement a very versatile API that
unlocks the full potential of the game
like for example mind Doo supports
multimodal observation um and a full
action space like moving or tag or
Inventory management and then it can be
customized at every detail like you can
tweak uh the terrains the weather block
placement monster spawning and just
anything you want to customize in the
game and given this simulator we
introduce around 1500 programmatic tasks
which are tasks that have ground true
success conditions defined in Python
code and you can also explicitly write
down like the spars or ADV reward
functions using this API and some
examples are like harvesting different
resources unlocking the tech tree uh or
fighting various monsters and getting
reward and all these tasks come with
language prompts that are
templated next we also introduced 1500
creative tasks that are free form and
open-ended and that is in contrast to
the programmatic task I just men
so for example let's say we want the
agent to build a house but what makes a
house a house right it is El defined and
just like image generation you don't
know if it generates a cat correctly or
not so it's very difficult to use Simple
python programs to give these kind of
task reward functions and uh the best
way is to use Foundation models train on
internet skill knowledge so that the
model itself understands abstract
Concepts like you know the concept of a
house and finally there's one task that
holds a very special status called play
through which is to beat the final boss
of Minecraft the Ender Dragon so
Minecraft doesn't force you to do this
task as we said it doesn't have a fixed
story line but it's still considered a
really big milestone for any kind of
beginner human
players um I want to highlight it is an
extremely difficult task that requires
very complex preparation exploration and
also martial skills and for an average
human it would take um many hours or
even days to solve easily over like one
million action steps in a single episode
and that would be the longest
benchmarking task for policy learning
ever created here so I I admit I am
personally a below average human I was
never able to beat Ender Dragon and my
friends laugh at me and I'm like okay
one day my AI will avenge my poor skills
right that was one of the motivations
for this
project now let's move on to the second
ingredient the internet skill knowledge
based part of my indal we offer three
data sets here the YouTube Wiki and
Reddit and combined they are the largest
open-ended agent Behavior database ever
compiled to our
knowledge the first is YouTube and we
already said Minecraft is one of the
most streamed games on YouTube and
Gamers love to R what they're doing so
we collected more than 700,000 videos
with two billion words in the
corresponding
transcripts and these transcripts will
help the agent learn about human
strategies and creativities without us
manually labeling
things and second the Minecraft player
base is so crazy that they have compiled
a huge Minecraft specific Wikipedia that
basically explains everything
you ever need to know in every version
of the game it's crazy and we script
7,000 wikip pages with inter leing
multimodal data like images tables and
diagrams and here are some screenshots
like this is a gallery of all of the
monsters and their corresponding
behaviors like spawn and attack patterns
and also like the thousands of crafting
recipes are all present on the wiki and
we scrip all of them and more like
complex diagrams and tables and embedded
figures now we have something like gbd4
V it may be able to understand many of
these
diagrams and finally the Minecraft
subreddit is one of the most active
forums across entire the entire Reddit
and players showcase their creations and
also ask questions for help so we scrap
more than 300,000 posts from Minecraft
reddit and here are some examples of how
people use the Reddit as a kind of stack
Overflow for Minecraft
and we can see that some of the top
voted answers are actually quite good
like someone is asking oh why doesn't my
weat form grow and the answer says you
need to light up the room with more
torches you don't have enough
lighting now given the massive task
suite and internet data we have the
essential components to build journalist
agents so in the first mind Doo paper we
introduce a foundation model called M
clip and the idea is very simple I can
explain
slides basically for our YouTube
database we have time aligned videos and
transcripts and these are actually the
real tutorial videos from our data set
you see on on on the third clip you know
as I raise my a in front of this pig
there's only one thing that you know is
going to happen this actually someone
said this a big YouTuber of
Minecraft and then given this data we
train M Clip In The Same Spirit as
opening a clip so for those who are
unfamiliar open clip is a contrastive
model that learns the association
between image and its caption and here
it's a very similar idea but this time
it is a video text contrasted model um
and we associate the text with a video
snippet that runs about 8 to 16 seconds
each and intuitively mcub learns the
association between the video and a
transcript that describes the activity
in the video and M clip outputs a score
between zero and one where one means a
perfect correlation between the text and
video and zero means the text is
irrelevant to the activity so you see
this is effectively a language prompted
Foundation reward model that knows the
nuances of things like forests animal
behaviors and architectures in
Minecraft so how do we use mine Clip In
Action here's an example of our agent
interacting with the simulator and here
the task is share sheep to obtain
wall and as the agent explores in the
simulator it generates a video snipping
as a moving window which can be encoded
and fed into mine Club along with an
encoding of the text prompt
here and mine Club computes the
association right the higher the
association is the more the agents's
behavior in this video aligns with the
language which is task you wanted to do
and that becomes a reward function to
any reinforcement learning
algorithm so this looks very familiar
right because it's essentially RL from
Human feedback or
RF in
Minecraft and RF was the Cornerstone
algorithm that made chbt possible and I
believe it will play a critical role in
journalist agents as
well I'll quickly gloss over some
quantitative results I promise there
won't be like many tables of numbers
here for these eight tasks we show the
percentage success rate over 200 Test
episodes and here in the green circle is
two variants of our M clip method and in
in the orange circles are the
baselines so I'll highlight one Baseline
which is that we construct a dense
reward function manually for each task
using the Mind Doo API it's a python API
and you can consider this column as a
kind of Oracle the upper bound of the
performance because we put a lot of
human efforts into designing these
reward functions just for the
tasks and we can see that mine clip is
able to match the quality of many of
these not all of them but many of these
manual engineer rewards it is important
to highlight that mine clip is open
vocabulary so we use a single model for
all of these tasks instead of one model
for each and we simply prompt the reward
model with different tasks and and
that's the only
variation one major feature of
foundation model is strong
generalization out the box so can our
agent generalize to dramatic changes in
the visual appearance so we did this
experiment where during training we only
train our agents on a default terrain at
noon on sunny day but we tested zero
chart in a diverse range of terrains
weathers and day night cycles and you
can customize everything in mind
and in our paper we have numbers showing
that mine Club significantly beat an
off-the-shelf visual encoder when facing
these kind of distribution shift out the
box and this is no surprise right
because mine clip was trained on
hundreds of thousands of clips from uh
Minecraft videos on
YouTube which have a very good coverage
of all the
scenarios and I think that is just
attestment to uh the big advantage of
using internet skill data because you
get robustness on the
box and here are some demos of our learn
agent behaviors on various tasks so you
may notice that these T are relatively
short around like 100 to 500 time steps
and that is because M clip is not able
to plan over very long time time
Horizons and it is inherently it is an
inherent limitation in the training
pipeline because we could only use eight
to 16 seconds of the video so it's
constrained to like short actions but
our hope is to build an asent that can
explore and make new discoveries
autonomously just all by itself and it
keeps going and in 2022 this goal seems
quite Out Of Reach For Us mind Dojo was
June
2022 and this year something happened
and that is
gp4 a language model that's so good at
coding and long Horizon planning so we
just cannot sit still right we build
Voyager the first large language model
powered life on learning agent and when
we set Voyager lose in Minecraft we see
that it just keeps going and by the way
all these video Snippets are from a
single episode of Voyer it's not from
different different episodes It's a
single one and we see that Voyager is
just able to keep exploring the terrains
mine all kinds of materials fight
monsters craft hundreds of recipes and
unlock an ever expanding tree of diverse
skills so how how do we do
this if we want to use the full power of
gp4 a central question is how to
stringify things converting this 3D
world into a textual
representation we need a magic box here
and thankfully again the crazy Minecraft
Community already built one for us and
it's been around for many years it's
called M flare a high level JavaScript
API that's actively maintained to work
with any Minecraft version and the
beauty of M FL is it has access to the
game States surrounding agent like the
nearby blocks animals and enemies so we
effectively have a ground truth
perception module as textual input and
at the same time mind fler also supports
action apis that we can compose
skills and now that we can convert
everything to text we are ready to
construct an agent on top of gb4 so on a
high level there are three components
one is a Cod module that writes
JavaScript code to control the game bot
and it's the main module that generates
the executable actions and second we
have a code base to store the correctly
written code and look it up in the
future if the agent needs to recall the
skill and in this way we don't duplicate
efforts and whenever facing similar
situations in the future the agent knows
what to do and third we have a
curriculum that Pro proposes what to do
next given the agent's current
capability p and also
situation and when you wire these
components up together you get a loop
that drives the agent in definitely and
Achieve something like LIF La
learning so let's zoom in the center
module we prompt gd4 with documentations
and examples on how to use a subset of
the Mind flare API and uh gd4 Rights
Code to take actions given the current
assigned task and because JavaScript
runs a coding interpreter gbd4 is able
to Define functions on the Fly and run
it
interactively but the code that gb4 wres
isn't always correct right just like
human geners you can get everything
correct on the first try so we developed
an iterative prompting mechanism to
refine the program and there are three
types of feedback here the environment
feedback like you know what are the new
materials you got after taking an action
or you know some enemies nearby and the
execution error from the JavaScript
interpreter if you wrote some buggy code
like undefined variable for example if
it hallucinates something um and another
gb4 that provides critique through
self-reflection from the Asian State and
the world State and that also helps
refine the program
effectively so I want to show some quick
example of how the critic provides
feedback on the task completion progress
so let's say in the first example the
task is to craft a spy glass and Jud for
looks at the agent's inventory and
decides that it has enough copper but
not enough Amhurst as a
material and the second task is to kill
three sheeps to collect food and each
ship drops one unit of wool but there
are only two units in inventory so you
for reasons and says that okay you have
one more ship to go and
likewise now moving on to the second
part once Voyer implements a skill
correctly we save it to a persistent
storage and you can think of the skill
Library as a code repository written
entirely by a language model through
interaction with a 3D world and the
agent can record new skills and also
retrieve skills from the library facing
similar situations in the future so it
doesn't have to go through this whole
program refinement that we just saw
again which is quite inefficient but you
do it once you save it to to disk and in
this way Voyager kind of bootstraps its
own capabilities recursively as it
explores and experiments in the
game and let's dive a little bit deeper
into how the skill library is
implemented so this is how we insert a
new skill first we use gbd 3.5 to
summarize the program into plain English
and summarization is very easy and gbd4
is expensive so we just you know go for
a cheaper a cheaper tier um and then we
embed this summary as the key and we
save the program which is a bunch of
code as the value and we find that doing
this makes retrieval better because the
summary is more semantic and the code is
a bit more discrete and and you insert
it and now for the retrieval process
when voyag is faced with a new task
let's say craft iron pickaxe we again
use GB 3.5 to generate a hint on how to
solve the task and that is something
like a natural language paragraph and
then we embed that and use that as the
query into the vector database and we
retrieve the scill
from from the library so you can think
of it as a kind of in context replay
buffer in the reinforcement learning
literature and now moving on to the
third
part we have another gb4 that proposes
what task to do given its own
capabilities at the moment and here we
give gbd4 a very high level kind of
unsupervised objective that is to obtain
as many unique items as possible that is
our high level directives and then gb4
takes this directive and implements um a
curriculum of progressively harder
challenges and more novel challenges to
solve so it's kind of like curiosity
exploration where um it is called
novelty search in a prior literature but
implement it purely in context yeah if
you're listening to zoom the next
example is
fun let's let's go through this example
together right um just to kind of show
you how how voy works the the whole
complicated data flow that I just show
so the Asian finds itself hungry um it
only has one out of 20 hunger bar so it
knows gb4 knows that it needs to find
food ASAP and then it senses there are
four entities nearby a cat a villager a
pig and some wheat seeds and now gb4
starts a self-reflection right like do I
kill the cat and villager to get some
meat that sounds horrible um how about
the wheat seeds um I can use the seeds
to grow a farm but that's going to take
a very long time until I can generate
some food so sorry piggy you are the one
being chosen so gb4 looks at the
inventory which is the agent State there
is a piece of iron in inventory so it
recalls voy recalls a skill from the
library that is to craft an iron sword
and then use that skill to start
pursuing to start learning a new skill
and that is hunt Pig and once the hunt
Pig uh routine is successful GT4 saves
it to the skill Library that's roughly
how it
works yeah and putting all these
together we have this it prompting
mechanism the scale library and an
automatic curriculum and all of these
combined is voyages no gradient
architecture where we don't train any
new models or fine tune any parameters
and allows allows voer to self bootstrap
on top of gb4 even though we are
treating the underlying language model
as a black box
it looks like my my example work and
they started to started to
listen
yeah so yeah these are the tasks that
Voyager picked up along the way and we
didn't program any of these it's all vo
just idea the agent is kind of forever
curious and also forever pursuing new
adventures just by
itself um so to quickly show some
quantitative results here we have a
learning curve where the xaxis is the
number of prompting iterations and the Y
AIS is the number of unique items that
Voyager discovered as it's exploring in
environment and uh these two curves are
baselines react and
reflexion and this is autog gbt which is
like a popular software repo basically
you can think of it as combining react
and a task planner that decomposes an
objective into sub goals and this is
Voyager we're able to obtain three times
more novel items than the prior methods
and also unlock the entire Tech Tree
significantly faster um and if you take
away the skill Library you see that
voice really suffers the the performance
takes a hit because every time it needs
to kind of repeat and relearn every
skill from scratch and it starts to make
a lot more mistakes and that really
degrades the
exploration here these two are the bird
eyye views uh of the Minecraft map and
these circles are what the prior methods
are able to explore given the same
prompting iteration budget and we see
that they tend to get stuck in local
areas and kind of fail to explore more
but the Voyager is able to navigate
distances at least two times as much as
the PRI works so it's able to visit a
lot more places because to satisfy this
high level directive of obtaining as
many unique items as possible You' got
to travel right if you stay at one place
you will quickly exhaust interesting
things to do and voy travels a lot so
that's how we came up with the
name so finally um one limitation is
that Voyager does not currently support
visual perception because the gd4 that
we used back then was text only but
there's nothing stopping Voyer from
adopting like multimodal language models
in the future so here we have a little
proof of concept demo where we ask a
human to basically function as the image
captioner and the human will tell
Voyager that as you're building these
houses what are the things that missing
like you you place a door incorrectly uh
like the roof is also not done correctly
so the human is acting as a Critic
module of the voer stack and we see that
with some of that help Voyer is able to
build a farmhouse and a nether portal
but it has a hard time understanding
sending you know 3D spatial coordinates
just by itself in a textual
domain now after doing voer we're
considering like where else can we apply
this idea right of coding in embod
environment observe the feedback and
iteratively refine the program so we
came to realize that physics simulations
themselves are also just python code so
why not apply some of the principles
from voer and do something in another
domain what if you apply Voyager in the
space of this physics simulator API and
this is urea which uh my team announced
just like three days ago freshh out of
the oven it is an open-ended agent that
designs reward functions for robot
dexterity at superh human level and it
turns out that GT4 plus reinforcement
learning can spin a pen much better than
I do I gave up on the this task a long
time ago from childhood it's so hard for
me so urea idea is very simple and
intuitive gbd4 generates a bunch of
possible reward function candidates
implementing in Python and then you just
do a full reinforcement uh reinforcement
learning training Loop for each
candidate in a GPU accelerated
simulator and you get a performance
metric and you take the best candidates
and feedback to gb4 and it samples the
next proposals of candidates and keeps
improving the whole population of the
reward functions that's a whole idea
it's kind of like an in context
evolutionary
search so here's the initial reward
generation where urea takes as context
the environment code of nvidia's ISAC
Sim and a task description and samples
the initial reward function
implementation so we found that the
simulator code itself is actually very
good reference manual because it tells
you Raa what are the variables you can
use uh like you know the hand positions
like here the fingertip position the
finger TP State the rotation angular
velocity Etc so you know all of these
variables from the simulator code and
you know how they interact with each
other so that serves as a very good uh
like in context instruction so urea
doesn't need to reference Any Human
return reward
functions and then once you have the
generated reward you plug it into any
reinforcement learning algorithm and
just train it to completion so this step
is typically very costly and very slow
because reinforcement larning itself is
slow and we were only able to scale up
urea because of nvdi section which runs
a thousand simulated environment copies
on a single GPU so basically you can
think of it as speeding up Reality by a
thousand
a and then after training you will get
the performance metrics back on each
reward component and as we on Voyager
gbd4 is very good at self-reflection so
we leverage that capability and
uh there's a software trial reminding
you to activate the
license yeah so uh Voyager reflects on
it and then uh proposes mutations on the
code so here the mutations uh we found
can be very diverse ranging from
something as simple as just changing a
hyperparameter in the reward function
waiting to all the way to adding
completely novel components to the
reward
function and in our experiments urea
turns out to be a superhuman reward
engineer actually outperforming some of
the functions implemented by the expert
human Engineers on Nvidia i6m
team so here are some more demos of how
urea is able to write very complex
rewards that lead to these extremely Dex
dexterous behaviors and we can actually
train the robot hand to rotate pens not
just you know in One Direction but in
different directions along different 3D
axis I think one major contribution of
urea different from Voyager is to bridge
the gap between high level reasoning and
lowlevel mod controls so urea introduces
a new paradig that I'm calling hybrid
gradient architecture so recall Voyer is
a no gradient architecture we don't
touch anything and we don't train
anything but urea is a hybrid gradient
where a black box influence only
language Model instructs A white box
learnable neuron Network so you can
think of it as two Loops right the alter
Loop is great and free and it was it's
driven by gd4 kind of selecting the
reward functions and the inner loop is
grade and based you train like a full
reinforcement learning episode from it
to achieve extreme dexterity using a
specialized like training by training a
special neuron network controller and
you must have both Loops to succeed to
deliver this kind of dexterity and I
think it will be a very useful Paradigm
for training robot agents in the
future so you know these days when I go
on Twitter or X I see AI conquering new
LS like every we you know chat image
generation and music they're all very
well within reach but mind Dojo voy and
urea these are just scratch on the
surface of open-ended journalist
agents and looking forward I want to
share two key research directions that I
personally find extremely promising and
I'm also working on it myself the first
is a continuation of Mind Club basically
how to develop methods that learn from
internet skill video videos and the
second is multimodal foundation models
now that gp4 V is coming but it is just
the beginning of an era and I think it's
important to have all all of the
modalities in a single Foundation
model so first about
videos we all know that videos are
abundant right like so many data on
YouTube way too many for our limited
gpus to
process they're extremely useful to try
models that not only have Dynamic
perception and intuitive physics but
also capture the complexity of human
creativity and human behaviors it's all
good except
that when you are using video to
pre-rain the embodied agents there is
huge distribution shift you also don't
get action labels and you don't get any
of the groundings because you're a
passive
Observer so I think here is a
demonstration of why learning from video
is hard even for natural
intelligence so little cat is seeing
boxers shaking their head and it thinks
maybe shaking head is the best way to to
do
fighting right this is why learning from
video is
hard you have you have you have no idea
like
why this is too good let's let's play
this again you have you have no idea why
Tyson is doing this right like the cat
has no idea and then it Associates this
with just wrong wrong kind of
policy but for sure it you know it
doesn't help the fighting but it
definitely boosts the cat's
confidence that's why learning from
video is
hard now I want to point out a few kind
of latest research in how to leverage so
much video for journalist agents um
there are a couple of approaches the
first is the simplest just learn kind of
a visual feature extractor from the
videos
so this is r3m uh from Chelsea's group
at Stanford uh and this model is still
an image level representation just that
it uses a video level loss function to
train um more specifically time
contrasted learning and after that you
can use this as um an image backbook for
any agent but you still need to kind of
find tune uh using domain specific data
for the
agent the second path is to learn reward
functions from video and M clip is uh
one model under this category it uses a
contrastive objective between the
transcri and video and here this work
VIP is another way to learn a similarity
based reward for goal condition tasks in
the image space so this work VIP is led
by who's also the first author of urea
and uh urea is his internship project
with
me and the third idea is very
interesting can we directly do imitation
learning from video but better than the
cat right that that we just saw so we
just said you know the videos don't have
the actions right we need to find some
ways to Pudo label the actions and this
is video training of vpt from open AI
last year to solve longrange task in
Minecraft and here the the pipeline
works like this basically you use a
keyboard and a mouse action space so you
can align this action space with the
human actions and open air hires a bunch
of Minecraft players and actually
collect data in house so they record the
episodes done by those Gamers and now
you have a data set of image of video
and action pairs right and you train
something called an inverse Dynamics
model which is to take the observation
and then predict the actions that caused
the observation to change so that's
inverse Dynamics model and that becomes
a
labeler that you can apply to IND the
wild YouTube videos that don't have the
actions so you applied IDM to like 70k
hours of in the wild YouTube videos and
you will get these pseudo actions that
are not always correct but also way
better than random and then you train
imitation learning on top of this
augmented data set and in this way opena
is able to greatly expand uh the data
because the original uh data collected
from the humans are high quality but
they're extremely expensive while in the
wild YouTube videos are very cheap but
you don't have the options so they kind
of solved um and got the best of those
RS but still you know it's really
expensive to hide these
humans now what's beyond videos right
I'm a firm believer that multimodal
models will be the future and I see Tex
as a very lossy kind of ond projection
of our physical world so it's essential
to include the other sensory modalities
to provide a full inod experience and in
the context of of embodied agents I
think the input will be a mixture of
text images videos and even audio in the
future and the output will be
actions so here's a very early example
of a multimodal language model for robot
learning so let's imagine a household
robot we can ask a robot to bring us a
cup of tea from the kitchen but if we
want to be more specific I want this
particular cup that is my favorite cup
so show me this image and we also
provide a video demo of how we want to
mop the floor and ask the robot to
imitate the similar Motion in
context and when a robot sees an
unfamiliar object like a sweeper we can
explain it by providing an image and
showing this is a sweeper now you know
go ahead and do something with the tool
and finally to ensure safety we can say
take a picture of that room and just do
not enter that
room to achieve this um back last year
we proposed a model called Vima which
stands for visual motor attention and in
this work we introduce a concept called
multimodal prompting where the prompt
can be a mixture of the text image and
videos and this provides a very
expressive API that just unifies a bunch
of different robot tasks that otherwise
would require a very different pipeline
or specialized models to solve in Prior
literature and VMA simply tokenizes
everything uh converting image and text
into sequences of tokens and train a
Transformer on top to Output the robot
arm actions autor regressively one step
at a time during inference
time so just to look at some of the uh
examples here like this prompt rearrange
objects to match the scene it is a
classical task called visual goal
reaching that has a big body of Prior
works on it and uh that's how our robot
does it given this prompt and we can
also give it uh novel Concepts in
context like this is a bliet this is a w
now put a w into a bid and both words
are nonsensical so it's not in the
training data but VMA is able to
generalize zero shot and follow the
motion to manipulate this object so the
bot understands what we want and then
follow this trajectory and finally we
can give it more complex prompt like you
know these are the safety constraints
sweep the box into this but without
exceeding that line and uh we we do this
using the inter leaving image and text
tokens and recently Google brain
robotics follow up after VMA with rt1
and rt2 robot Transformer one and two uh
and rt2 is using a similar recipe as uh
I described where they first kind of
pre-train uh on internet scale data and
then fine-tune with some human collected
demonstrations on the Google robots and
Robocat from Deep line is another
interesting work and they train a single
Unified policy that works not just on a
single robot but actually across
different embodiments different robot
forms and even generalize to a new
hardware so I think this is like a
higher form of multimodal agent where
the physical form factor the morphology
of the agent itself is another
modality so that concludes our looking
forward uh
section and lastly I want to kind of
just put all links together of the works
I describe so this is mind do.org we
have U open source everything well for
all the projects where big fans are open
source we open source as much as we can
including like the model code
checkpoints um simulator code and
training
data and this is Voyager mind.org this
is
urea and this is
Vima and one more thing right if you
just want an excuse to play Minecraft at
work that mind do is perfect for you
because you are collecting human
demonstration to train jous asent and if
there's one thing that you take away
from this talk it should be this
slide and lastly I I just want to remind
all of us you know despite all the
progress I've shown right what we can do
is still very far from Human Ingenuity
as embodied agents you know these are
the videos from our data set of people
doing like decorating Winter Wonderland
or building the functioning CPU circuit
within Minecraft and we are very far
from that as AI research so here's a
call to the community if human can do
these mind-blowing tasks then why not
our AI right let's find out
together